("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Matts Idea" by JR.)
I like her hustle.
It's 5:41 in the
morning in the airport
and she is grinding.
Let's go red sweater.
Bringing it.
Just got done with
pitch, AJV, Bri, Mook.
Went well, was exciting.
Great kid, great fam
we'll see what happens.
Vayner Sports early days.
I'm sure me and AJ are
thinking about the same thing.
Just reminds me so much
of early VaynerMedia.
Same thing and you
know what that means.
The outcome's gonna be good.
Game over, AJ it's game over.
They don't know yet but this
time we're documenting it.
This time we're documenting it.
Good job, boys, really excited.
Going to an airBnB to catch a
Jets game and then heading back
to L.A., that's what's going on.
Brian.
- [Brian] 'Sup man?
- [Gary] You got a lot of
shit for a short little trip.
- Yeah, over packers
of the world, unite.
- We're also spending the night
and going to
another meet tomorrow.
- [Gary] See, that was
the right answer Bri.
Good job, AJ.
I got nothin.
I literally
traveled with nothing.
Quick little stop,
watch a Jets game.
Just about to post a
new episode of DailyVee.
Short little one for yesterday,
short little one for today.
Weekends are always gonna be a
little tricky depending
on the situation.
But more fun, more
insight to my day to day.
Just kind of different
scenes, different parts of life.
Only so much I can show you
of meeting after meeting after
meeting but
Sunday, holiday time.
I hope all of you are doing
some gift shopping.
Spending time with the fam,
enjoying yourselves,
living life, watching football.
I'm deeply intensely right now
thinking about
VaynerMedia 2017
and strategizing.
New clients, off-loading
some clients, different stuff.
I got VaynerTalent exploding.
Good stuff going on.
Jets FaceTime, screen
time from New York.
AJ we're in an airBnB.
This is how it happens
when you're 3 and 9.
Oh Jesus!
The Jets won in
overtime against the 49ers.
I'm disgusted because
I really actually
wanted to lose
but it is what it is.
You know, the team fought and
that's what they do and the
coaching staff and so kudos
to them on the come back.
Now I'm just
getting to the airport.
Long day, Vayner Sports.
Fly to Atlanta, (laughs)
I day trip to Atlanta.
I commuted to Atlanta for a
meeting, caught the Jets with my
brother and now
heading back to L.A.
land around midnight L.A. time.
Gotta be up at
6 A.M. working out.
Just grinding.
Grinding while they're sleeping.
I'm glad you stopped by.
- Rad man.
- I'm glad you
stopped by and said hello.
- Thanks, brother.
Take care.
- [Gary] Have a great
holiday, take care.
I will watch zero minutes
and zero seconds of this game
because I hate football.
("Matts Idea" by JR.)
I always love this part.
A little cool in December and
now I'm just gonna work on email
for the next four hours.
Grind for four hours.
Get to L.A. at midnight.
Constant hustle.
You know, you know how it is.
Super glamorous
being an entrepreneur.
Super fun and easy.
Private planes and
models and shit.
Such bullshit.
It's all about the grind.
Vayner Nation,
it's midnight L.A.
I woke up at 4:30 A.M. L.A. time
so
we've been on a
17 and a half, 18 hour grind.
Flew in for one
meeting in Atlanta
and flew back on a rest day
and a weekend
and a holiday weekend
in December 'cause I was
out here filming
"Planet of the Apps."
Just a classic example
of putting in the work. Right?
Not too many people willing to
take two cross country flights
for one meeting but Vayner
Sports is a young company and
when you have your first year
the ability to be in the finals
of a first round pick and get
a chance to sign a first
round pick you do it.
AJ reached out and said, "Bri
and Mook and I feel like we need
"you for this one," and
so I made it happen.
It's tough, it's tiring but
your actions have to
match your ambition.
If I'm gonna talk shit about how
well Vayner is gonna do,
Vayner Sports, then I need to
back it up with this kind of
hustle and grind.
So if you don't want to put
in the work, shut your mouth.
("Matts Idea" by JR.)